[音楽]
おっ
mood ん
私は今会社を経営しているんですけども
実は起業する前はニートだったんです
しかも普通のニートじゃなくて
グローバルニートっていうかっこいい名前
のニートで
世界中を一膳ほどかけて旅行してました
世界中を旅行するって言うと皆さん
ゴージャスなホテルに泊まってバカンス
みたいな感じ想像すると思うんですけれど
も私の場合は1泊600円
12人部屋レイズ運んでえっ現地の人と
ぬるいビールでカンパーイみたいな感じで
夜になるとこんな風にグチャグチャになり
ます
生まれ育った環境が違う人と一緒にご飯を
食べてお酒を飲んで国籍とか肌の色とか
関係なく友達になって
いっぱい話してると普段は自分が意識すら
していなかったようなことにハッと
気づかされて考え方が変わることがあり
ます
今日はそんな旅で得た気づきから私が起業
して
常識外れと言われたやり方で御門はぬご
褒美を受け取った秘訣をお話しします
いつかは世界新に行くのが夢っていう人
って多いですよね
私は世界周だけじゃ足りなくって世界を2
周しちゃったんです
そんな旅の中のある日
仲良くなったトルコ人の友達のディレク
ちゃんから疲れたんです
目をキラキラ輝きするながら
私もいつか花子みたいに世界週に行きたい
いくらくらいお金止めればいいの教えて
って聞いてきたんです
私はバックパッカーだったので1年で使っ
た金額ってだいたい200万円くらいでし
た
200万円という金額はもちろん大きな
金額です
でも200万円で1年間世界常緑をでき
るって言われたらどうでしょうか
私もお金貯めて行ってみたい
そうふうに思った方もいらっしゃるんじゃ
ないでしょうか
そんな風に私はディレクちゃんを勇気づけ
たくって金額を伝えたんです
200万円くらいでようって
そしたらてぃ歴ちゃんが急に悲しそうな校
に代わってこういったんです
インポスティブルー
私は何も言えなくなって
あとでネットで調べました
トルコ人の平均月収は約7万円
これに対して日本人の平均月収は30万円
以上あるんです
私と履歴ちゃんとで200万円を貯める
ことの難しさが全然違ったんです
ただ生まれてきた国が違うって言うだけで
いい
せっかく仲良くなったのに
私とテレちゃんとの間には見えない壁が
あるように感じました
こんなふうに私は旅の中で生まれた環境に
よって人生の可能性が制限されてしまって
いる友達にたくさん出会いました
旅の前からもちろん私も格差については
知ってました
でも先進国に生まれたっていうだけで自分
がアドバンテージを持っててそれを使って
るって意識したことがまったくなかったん
です
これに気づいた時私はせっかく
アドバンテージを持ちながら何もしてこ
なかった自分がすごく恥ずかしくて嫌に
なったしいっぱい優しくしてくれた友達に
何かお返しがしたい
そのためには各さを何とかしなきゃいけな
いって思ったんです
でも
そもそも一体何で草ってあるんでしょうか
先進国と発展途上国だけじゃないですよ
ねー
教育を受ける機会の格差なんていうのも
最近話題になりましたし
格差社会なんて言葉もあります
世の中ってか[ __ ]だらけじゃないですか
変ですよねだって落とした町民の格差は
良くない無くした方がいいっていつも言っ
てるのに格差は一向になくならぬ
みんな嘘ついてるんでしょうか
違うんです
格差をよくないって思ってたとしても注意
しないと人間は無意識の悪い修正によって
格差をつくって結果みんなが損をしちゃう
んです
いくつもの実験で人は強い立場に立つとき
にその立場を無意識にかつ積極的に利用
する傾向があることがわかっています
立場を利用して酷い扱いをされても弱い
立場の人は受け入れるしかない
でもそうしてると頑張っての無駄だって
感じてやる気をなくしちゃうそしたら余計
に力の差が広がる
こんなマイナスの循環によって格差が
生まれて
最終的には弱い立場の人かもうメリダンっ
てなってしまってストライキを起こしたり
潰れてしまったりして結局みんなが損する
んです
無意識に格差を作り出して結局みんなそう
してるって人限定
なんて愚かな生き物なんでしょうねぇ
でもね人間のことを擁護するわけじゃない
んですけど
人間にもすごくいいところがあるんです
何かをしてもらったらお返しをしたくなる
習性とか他人を助けることで自分も幸せを
感じることができる
んない修正もあります
私たちの1周性を妨げて悪い習性を
引き出している原因っていうのは実は立場
の差だったんです
私は一つの仮説を立てました
自分が強い立場に立つときに弱い立場の人
が頑張れるように環境を整える
そしたら用意立場の人はうれしくなって
頑張ってお返しをしてくれる
その頑張りに応じて一旦そうしてでも報酬
を支払う
ここしたら弱い立場の人はさらに頑張って
を回収してくれる
こんなプラスの循環をつくることができれ
ばみんなかお得するんじゃないかなって
この仮説に基づいて私はキーを押しました
注目したのは日払いの人材派遣の業界です
私は自分が派遣労働者として働いていた
経験があったので知ってたんですけど
日払いの人材派遣の業界って1日単位で
働けるから外国籍の方はもちろんのことを
病気や育児や介護など弱い立場の方の
受け皿になってたんです
でもその立場の弱さにつけこんで派遣会社
が酷い扱いするっていうことが頻繁に
起こっていました
早くこの業界から足を洗ったほうがいいお
だって私たちは
どうせ仕えしてだからっ
これは実際に私が派遣労働者として働いて
た時に同僚に言われた言葉です
だから私は弱い立場の派遣労働者の人が
頑張れるような環境を整える
そして頑張りに応じて一旦そうしてでも
報酬を支払う
こんな常識外れの派遣会社を作ることにし
ました
仕事する上で何が困ってるのって聞いたら
メイクやみなし前に押し方がわからないっ
ていう人が多かったから
自分で教えたり仕事に来ていくような服が
ないっていう子には持ってる服を貸したり
揚げたりしました
あんまりにも親身に相談乗りすぎて家の
電気止められたから者が貸してって言われ
た言葉であります
そして気持ちよく働いてもらうために
頑張りに応じて業界の水準よりもずっと
高い報酬を利益を減らしてでも支払うこと
にしました
最初はお金もそんなになかったので正直
ひどいなって思いましたけどねぇ
この常識外れのやり方には起業した当初
反対意見ばかりでした
甘いとかそんなのうまくいくわけないよー
とか
たくさんの人に馬鹿にされました
でも1年くらい知ったらみんなが逆に聞い
てくるようになったんです
どうやって経営してるのって
だって普通ではあり得ないような嬉しい
ことがどんどん起こるようになったんです
自分が働いてて良かったからと言って皆
友達とか家族とか恋人とか
自分の大事な人をどんどん連れてきて
くれるようになりました
だから採用にお金かけてないのに
たった5年で
38カ国に1800人以上もの仲間を作る
ことができました
そしてそうやって集まった仲間たちは
みんなモチベーションがすっごく高くて
払った報酬以上に頑張って働いてくれたん
です
私のもとにはみんなで写真撮ったから見
てって言って楽しそうに働いてる写真が
送られてくるようになりました
そのうちの一人は写真にこんな言葉を添え
てくれましたん
今までの人生で最高の3日間
クライアントは久野さんから紹介される子
はみんなめっちゃ頑張って働いてくれる
ねーって言って
どんどん口コミやリピートでの注文が
舞い込むようになりました
私の会社ではリピート率が8割を超えてて
営業はほとんどしてません
さらに
思わぬご褒美までついてきました
私たちの活動は段々と仕事っていう枠を
越えていったんです
これは融資を始めてボランティアで行った
民族衣装のファッションショーの様子です
みんなそれぞれの国の民族衣装を着こなし
て
笑顔で解くらしくだ運営を歩いてくれまし
た
そしてこの章のカメラマンはなんと
もともとクライアントだと人だったんです
年齢や国籍や立場を超えて私たちの活動を
応援してくれる方が増えてこの賞をみんな
で作り上げたんです
こんな風に皆が一つになって働いてる姿を
見るたびに最初は大変だったけど行動を
起こして本当によかったなって私自身も
幸せを感じてます
今までの話を聞いてもしかするとそんな
自分は強い立場になんてなることないし
関係ないって思われた方もいらっしゃるか
もしれません
でも実は次にプラスの循環を起こすのは
この話を聞いてくださっているあなたなん
です
世界中いたるところに隠さオアルってお
話ししました
ということは私たちは意識してないだけで
誰もが強い立場になることがあるって言う
ことなんです
そして強い立場に立ったときに悪い習性に
従って損をするのも
いい修正を引き出してご褒美を受け取るの
もあなたの行動次第なんです
大事なことは3つだけです
一つ目自分が立場を利用していないか常に
注意して見ておくこと
二つ目
弱い立場の人が頑張れるように環境を
整えること
みつめ頑張りに応じて一旦村してでも報酬
を支払うこと
当たり前のように聞こえますが実際は無
意識に悪い習性に従ってしまって損をし
てる残念な例の方が多いんです
例えばだ駅行と下請け企業の取引
立場を利用して下請けに不利な情景を飲ま
せている企業の話ってよく聞きませんか
不当な値下げの要求などを行ってしまって
使う気がもう無理だってなってしまって
事故が発生したり仕事の手抜きが発覚し
たりしてニュースにもなってますよね
最初は立場を利用することで曲を捨てる
ように見えるんですけど最終的には大ごと
になって世間の批判にさらされたり業績も
悪化したりして損をしてます
他にも同じ人間が名札を日本人の名前から
外国人の名前に変えるだけで相手から高圧
的な態度を取られるようになって
対応に追われてサービスの質が低下した
なんていう話もあります
逆に良い修正を引き出すことでご褒美を
受け取ってるでもあります
作業用のロボットを販売しているある大手
企業は下請け会社に自社のロボットを無償
で提供してます
これによって下請け企業の作業効率が
上がってその結果この大企業はより多くの
利益を手にしています
また絶対的な立場の差がある
運動部の先輩と後輩
先輩が自分の練習時間を削って
今まで身につけてきたノウハウを後半に
教えてあげる
そしたら後輩は先輩のために頑張りたいて
慕ってくれるようにある
その頑張りを先輩は労ってあげる
後輩のやる気はさらにアップして
結果チーム全体の雰囲気や成績まで良く
なる
こんな話って皆さんの周りでも聞いたこと
ありませんか
実はご褒美を受け取るための方法って
そんなに難しいものじゃなくてちょっと
意識して行動を変えるだけなんです
リーダーとか指導者上司先輩など自分が
強い立場に立つことが絶対みんなあると
思います
また特別な機会がなくっても先進国に
生まれたみたいに知らず知らずに強い立場
に立っていることがあるんです
だから皆さん自分が無意識に立場を利用し
ていないか注意して見ておいてください
そしてもし自分が悪い習性に従って
損をしていることに気づいたら
今日の話を思い出してください
弱い立場の人が頑張れるように環境を
整える
そして頑張りに応じて一旦そうしてでも
報酬を支払う
こんな行動で一人一人がプラスの循環を
つくることができてみんなが得をする
そうしてるといつの日にか私の様に思わぬ
ご褒美を受け取る日が来るでしょう
ご静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]